>> Greg: ALL RIGHT HAPPY
MONDAY EVERYONE.
GOOD TO SEE ALL I'M LINE.
SO ALL IS WHITE I MEAN RIGHT.
AND MARTHA'S VINEYARD AGAIN
CLOSE ONE.
AFTER A FRIGHTENING INTERACTION
WITH 50 HAPPY MIGRANTS THE BRAVE
CITIZENS OF THE RICH LIBERAL
ENCLAVE HANDLE THE MONUMENTAL
CRISIS BY CALLING IN THE
NATIONAL GUARD AND SHIPPING THEM
OFF TO AN AIR FORCE BASE.
DONALD TRUMP DIDN'T EVEN CALL IN
THE GUARD WHEN CITIES WERE
BURNED TO THE GROUND.
AND HERE THEY'RE CALLED IN FOR
VICKI MIGRANTS.
BUT I GET IT WHAT IF SOMEBODY
WANTED USE THE BATHROOM.
THEY WILL PROBABLY WANT SOME
FOOD RIGHT?
A GLASS OF WATER WE DON'T WANT
THAT SO WITHIN 48 HOURS THOSE
MIGRANTS WERE OFF MARTHA'S
VINEYARD FASTER THAN A KENNEDY
FLING A SUBMERGED VEHICLE.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THEY GET AWAY WITH
IT.
THEY ALWAYS GET AWAY WITH IT.
SO THEY REJECTED THE MIGRANTS
THE SAME WAY THEY REJECT GIANT
TURBINE WINDMILLS THAT DISTURB
THEIR VIEWS.
IT'S ANOTHER LIBERAL WET DREAM
THAT EXPOSED THE HYPOCRISY.
THE DEMOCRAT MOTTO SHOULD BE NOT
IN MY BACKYARD.
UNLESS YOU'RE THERE TO RAKE THE
LEAVES.
[APPLAUSE]
YES THE PROUD SANCTUARY CITY
WHEN FACED WITH BEING A
SANCTUARY CAN PUT UP OR SHUT UP.
SO THIS WAS ON THE MARK MIGRANTS
SHOWED UP.
>> WE DON'T HAVE THE SERVICES TO
TAKE CARE OF 50 IMMIGRANTS AND
WE CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE HOUSING
WE ARE IN A HOUSING CRISIS SO WE
CAN'T HAVE EVERYONE HERE THAT
LIVES HERE WORKSHARE.
WE DON'T HAVE HOUSING.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: AND NOW THIS IS THAT
WHEN A B.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GRASSY US STOMACH TONIC
.>> Greg: ADIOS AMIGOS.
DON'T LET IT HATE YOUR ON THE
WAY OUT.
WHAT A COMPASSIONATE TOWN IN THE
MEDIA AGREES ACCORDING TO CNN
THE MIGRANTS LEFT AN INDELIBLE
IMPRESSION ON HER ACCIDENTAL
HOST.
HOWEVER THE ACCIDENTAL?
BECAUSE THE HOST AND NICELY WANT
THEM THERE YOU IDIOTS.
WHEN IT COMES TO RECORDING ON
LIBERAL BEHAVIOR CNN CAN TURN
LEAP INTO BUTTER.
DON'T TRY THAT STEVE.
I KNOW YOU HAVE A COOKBOOK.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: AND AS FAR AS
INDELIBLE IMPRESSION IS THE
PEOPLE OF THE VINEYARD WHO LEFT
ONE.
AND IT'S WHAT PHONY RECESS THEY
WERE.
I'VE SEEN BIRD SANCTUARIES
HAPPIER TO TAKE IN CATS.
THEY ENRICHED US SAID AFTER THEY
SPENT JUST 44 HOURS THERE.
I GUESS IT'S WHAT YOU DO WHEN
SOMETHING ENRICHES YOU YOU TELL
IT TO LEAVE?
YOU'RE HAPPY TO LET THEM WORK
THERE, BUT NOT TO LIVE SO GET
THEM OUT.
HERE'S DeSANTIS ONE OF THE
PRESIDENT IS SCRAMBLING TO GET
HIS CABINET TOGETHER?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS SCRAMBLING
TO GET HIS CABINET TOGETHER.
HE DIDN'T SCRAMBLE TO GET US
CABINETS TOGETHER WHEN YOU 43,
53 MIGRANTS DIE IT'S ONLY WHEN
THEY HAVE 50 ILLEGAL ALIENS AND
UP IN A WEALTHY, RICH SANCTUARY
ENCLAVE THAT HE DECIDES TO
SCRAMBLE ON THIS.
>> Greg: HAVE TO HAND IT TO
DeSANTIS HE DID MORE THAN ANY
POLITICIAN ON FURTHERING THE
CONVERSATION ON IMMIGRATION.
WHO'S THE PARTY THAT ALWAYS SAYS
WE REALLY NEED TO FURTHER THE
CONVERSATION, IT'S ALWAYS THE
DEFICIT.
DARK IDEA OF CONVERSATION AND
SAY QUIETLY WILL I SCREAM IF YOU
WANT CONVERSATIONS LIKE THAT YOU
MIGHT AS WELL MARY KAT.
[LAUGHS]
DeSANTIS SAID IF YOUR
SANCTUARY CITY THEN BE ONE.
SO THERE IS YOUR CONVERSATION
YOU HYPOCRITES.
SO THE MEDIA FLUMMOXED WHEN
THEIR OWN PHONINESS IS EXPOSED
TO AN INCOHERENT TANTRUM.
>> LEAVING THEM ON A LITERAL
ISLAND DOESN'T HAVE ANY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP THEM AT
ALL.
IT'S INHUMANE.
>> FASCIST REPUBLICANS ARE
TRYING TO SHIP MIGRANTS AROUND
THE COUNTRY TO MAKE THEM SUFFER.
>> HERE IS SHORT RON DeSANTIS
AND GREG ABBOTT AND DUCEY WE
HATE IMMIGRANTS GET THE F OUT
AND WE WILL HELP YOU GET THE F
OUT.
>> Greg: WILL WHO SENT THEM
THE F OUT?
FOR THEM TO BE ANGRY THEY HAVE
TO REMEMBER THAT JOE BIDEN HAD
BEEN SITTING MIGRANTS ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
BUT YOU CAN'T BLAME THE NORMAL
PUBLIC AND SO I REPORT IT?
SO FINALLY HERE'S A SOLUTION TO
THE LIVES.
SPREAD THE CHALLENGE AROUND AND
INCLUDE THE STATES WHO BRAG
ABOUT THEIR SANCTUARY STATUS.
LOOK FOR ALL THIS TOGETHER
RIGHT?
WHETHER YOU'RE A STRUGGLING
FARMER ON THE TEXAS BORDER OR A
STRUGGLING FAMILY LIKE THE
OBAMA'S.
THAT 29-ACRE ESTATE IS NOT THE
LANDSCAPE ITSELF.
SO WHY IS ANYBODY SO OUTRAGED TO
THINK THAT THEY'RE BETTER THAN
YOU, THEY ARE EXEMPT, THEY HAVE
NO MASKS AT PARTIES, BUT YOU
WEAR THEM YOU CAN'T HAVE A GUN
BUT THEY HAVE PRIVATE SECURITY.
THE LOVE ALTERNATIVE ENERGY, BUT
THAT WHEN NO BETTER STAY IN YOUR
STATE.
EVERYTHING THEY PRETEND TO RAIL
THE EMBODY.
ALL THEY LOVE MIGRANTS WITH THE
LEAF BLOWERS, MAINLY BECAUSE THE
TOOLS OF THE USER SO LOUD GIVES
HIM A PERFECT EXCUSE NOT TO TALK
TO THEM.
FORMER NEW YORK GOVERNOR DAVID
PATTERSON SAID IT BEST.
THESE JERKS ARE JUST LIKE THE
WHITE LIBERALS WHO IMPOSE
INTEGRATION WAY BACK WHEN.
>> THEY DIDN'T WANT ANYONE
MOVING INTO THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
AS LONG AS IT WAS SOMEONE ELSE
WOULD LIVE WITH THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN'S ARE THE HISPANICS
MOVE NEIGHBORHOODS SO IT'S KIND
OF HISTORY REPEATING THEMSELVES
50 YEARS LATER.
>> Greg: THEY CALL THEMSELVES
PROGRESSIVE BUT THEIR BEHAVIOR
IS REGRESSIVE THEY CALL TEXANS
RACES FOR MOVING MIGRANTS AND
THEN THEY DO THE SAME THING.
THEY BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE AT
THE COMPASSIONATE ONES AS LONG
AS THEY DON'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY THINK THESE
MIGRANTS ARE TRASH OR DO THEY?
WHAT HERE IS A TWEET COMPARING
MIGRANTS THE TRASH.
AND WHO IS DOING IT?
LIBERALS, NOT EXTREME MACA WHICH
IS ONLY 70 CALORIES.
[LAUGHS]
THE WORST PART ABOUT ALL THIS IS
JAMES TAYLOR IS STILL SINGING.
♪ ♪
>> A MIGRANTS DON'T BE SO
WITHDRAWN THEY WILL PAY YOU TO
TAKE CARE OF YOUR LAWN.
COME ON DOWN TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD THE SEASONS OVER, BUT I
DON'T THINK YOU GUYS CARE ABOUT
THAT.
♪ ♪
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
>> Greg: YEAH.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
YOU CAN CLAP.
NO ONE IN A SANCTUARY CITY
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THEY HAD TO
WALK THE WALK.
THAT WHICH IS FOR YOU LOWLY
TYPES AND THE BORDER STATES.
THE MEDIA PLAYS ALONG BECAUSE
THEY ALL HOPE THAT ONE DAY THEY
WILL LIVE IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD
TOO, I'LL BE FROM THIS UNWASHED
MASSES LIKE YOU AND ME I'M
UNWASHED.
IT'S THE SAME MEDIA WHO LOVES
THE GOOD STUFF IN AND ELSA
REPUBLICANS AND OUTLINES A
SHAMEFUL AND THEY'RE RIGHT IT IS
SHAMEFUL.
THE BORDER STATES BROUGHT SHAME
TO THOSE WHO EXPRESS OUTRAGE NOW
WHEN THEY DIDN'T SEEM TO MIND
THE SUFFERING BY THEIR OWN
POLICIES THAT PROTECTED THEIR
LOVE FOR CHEAP LABOR.
THEY HYPOCRITES ARE MORE UPSET
BY BEING EXPOSED THAN THE REAL
SUFFERING THEY CAUSED BY THEIR
FALSE VIRTUE SIGNALING DEVELOP
THEM SHAME YOU FOR STARTING THE
CONVERSATION THAT THESE PHONIES
NEVER WANTED.
INSTEAD HERE'S ANOTHER SPANISH
PHRASE FOR ALL YOU LIBS THAT YOU
MIGHT WANT TO LEARN.
[LAUGHS]
♪ ♪
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME
TONIGHT'S GUESTS, HE HAS WON 11
EMMYS AND DESERVES A 12 FOR
ACTING LIKE --
FOX & FRIENDS AND AUTHOR OF THE
BOOK THE SIMPLY HAPPY COOKBOOK.
STEVE DOOCY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
JOE BIDEN WOULD CALL HIM AN
ULTRA MAGA DEMOCRACY ACTOR AND
COMEDIAN, TERRENCE WILLIAMS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SHE IS LIKE A JALAPENO SMALL,
SPICY, AND OFTEN SOAKED IN
TEQUILA.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND HIS TATTOO ARTIST NEEDS MORE
INK THAN IN YOUR POST.
MY MASSIVE SIZE CAKE AND THE
N.W.A. WORLD CHAMPION CHAMPION
TYRUS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
STEVE IS THE FIRST TIME THEY ARE
ON THE NIGHTLY SHOW?
>> I DIDN'T KNOW THEY HAD A SHOW
ON AFTER TUCKER?
>> Greg: I KNOW YOU'RE HERE
IT'S TO PUMP THIS BOOK IT'S THE
ONLY REASON WHY YOU'RE HERE AT
THE COOKBOOK THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
HERE YOU MAKE ME SICK TO MY
STOMACH WITH DEVILED EGGS.
THAT'S FOR ME DEVILED EGGS.
>> Steve: ACTUALLY GREG HAS A
REP OR SEE IN THEIR THE ENTIRE
CAST OF THE FIVE AND I BROUGHT
HIS INGREDIENT THAT HE IS
CONTRIBUTED.
HE PUTS HAS ON A CHARCUTERIE
BOARD.
>> Greg: YOU DON'T WANT TO
KNOW WHERE I PUT THE PEZ
DISPENSER.
[LAUGHS]
>> Steve: WHAT IS THAT LITTLE
THING NEXT TO YOU IS THAT A
BREATH MINT?
OR CAKE?
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT CONTROL
YOURSELF YOU'RE SICK GO THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE ON IN THE MORNINGS.
SO SMART ARE DONE MOVE BY
DeSANTIS?
>> Steve: BRILLIANT MOVE
RIGHT?
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: YOU ONLY APPLIED FOR
ME NOT THIS GUY.
>> Steve: ASKED ME THAT AGAIN.
YES RIGHT?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND HERE IS WHY.
OUT OF THIS, ESSENTIALLY VERY
EFFECTIVE.
NOW WE HAVE GAVIN NEWSOM
CHALLENGING DeSANTIS
ESSENTIALLY TO A DUEL.
I CHALLENGE YOU TO A DUEL.
LET'S DO A DEBATE HOWEVER
BECAUSE HE IS IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE GOVERNOR SAYING EVERYONE HAS
TO WASH YOUR DISHES AT MIDNIGHT,
IF THEY HAD A DEBATE FIRST OF
ALL IT CANNOT BE TELEVISED
BECAUSE USE ELECTRICITY.
I THINK THEY DID TO DEBATE FOR
12 GAVIN NEWSOM WHAT HAVE TO
WORK WITH A MASK AND THE VENUE
WOULD BE THE FRENCH LAUNDRY WHO
WOULDN'T WATCH.
RIGHT?
>> Greg: WHEN YOU CAN'T GET
CLOSE THERE.
TERRANCE IS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
YES IT HAS.
I LOVE HOW IT ALWAYS FEELS LIKE
IF THERE BEING A STUTTER BEING
USED AS PROPS WHAT ELSE DO
DEMOCRATS DO ON EVERY ISSUE?
>> Terrence: I DON'T KNOW BUT
I'D SURE LOVE A FREE PLANE RIDE.
CAN THEY DO THAT?
MY GOODNESS.
IT IS CRAZY TO THINK ABOUT
MARTHA'S VINEYARD THEY GOT RID
OF NEARLY 44 HOURS, THAT'S LIKE
RECORD-BREAKING RIGHT THERE.
I MEAN THEY MAY BORDER PATROL
LOOK BAD.
THEY MAKE HIM LOOK BAD.
THEY GOT UP AND OUT OF THERE
QUICKER THAN A TACO BELL
DRIVE-THROUGH.
[LAUGHS]
SERIOUSLY.
IT'S CRAZY.
>> Greg: IT'S BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WHAT?
THEY ENJOY THE SYMBOLISM OF THE
DON'T ACTUALLY ENJOY ENGAGING
THE PRACTICAL SOLUTION.
AND THAT'S WHERE YOU COME IN.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THIS?
>> Kat: YET THEY WERE JUST
THERE LONG ENOUGH TO TAKE
INSTAGRAM PHOTOS WITH THEM
[LAUGHS]
LIKE OF THEM HANDING THEM
SOMETHING TO BE LIKE THEY FELT
LIKE YOU WERE CHANGED BY IT AND
ALL THOSE THINGS A LOT OF IT IS
VIRTUE SIGNALING OBVIOUSLY.
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME SORT OF
SOLUTION HERE BECAUSE YOU CAN
BUS PEOPLE ALL AROUND, BUT NONE
OF THEM ARE ABLE TO GET JOBS
HERE OR ACTUALLY WORK WHICH IS
AN ISSUE.
I KNOW AT WHAT POINT IF THE NASS
PEOPLE TEXT TO SOMETHING I HOPE
THAT IT DOES BECAUSE HE NEEDS TO
BE DONE THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
I'M RATHER THAN SAYING ITS
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS TO SEND
SOMEONE TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD
WHICH I DON'T THINK.
>> Greg: IT'S DEFTLY NOT LIKE
THE HOLOCAUST.
>> Kat: THANKFULLY THE MOVING
MORE TOWARDS THE MIDDLE OR THEY
WOULD'VE SAID 9/11 AND THE
HOLOCAUST COMBINED.
THEY SAID YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE NEED TO BE MORE MODERATE.
>> Greg: TYRUS WOULD YOU MAKE
OF THIS?
DO YOU THINK IT'S TIME TO CALL
THESE GOVERNORS AND SITDOWN AND
HASH IT OUT?
>> Tyrus: MIGHT BE A BIT
EXTREME BECAUSE I KNOW WHAT IS
CALLING FOR.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THOUGH I
KIND OF FEEL FOR THE PEOPLE
MARTHA'S VINEYARD YOU KNOW?
IT WAS OFF-SEASON THEY WERE
ALREADY STAFFED YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU GONNA DO?
THE THING ABOUT THEY ARE THE
ORGANIZING HOUSING CRISIS YET
BECAUSE ARE ALL EMPTY.
DURING THE PEAK MONTHS THEY HOLD
UP TO 250,000 PEOPLE IN THE CUT
SOUNDED 30,000 OR SOME LIKE
THAT?
SO WHO'S GONNA FILL THOSE
HOUSES?
CERTAINLY NOT 50 PEOPLE.
[LAUGHS]
IF THEY SPREAD OUT WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO FIND THEM.
[LAUGHS]
[APPLAUSE]
SO AGAIN, AND SHAME ON
DeSANTIS.
[APPLAUSE]
YOU KNOW?
I LIKE BIG ROUND NUMBERS,
NOTHING SAYS MARTHA'S VINEYARD
LIKE A THOUSAND.
HOW HE WAS AT BIRTHDAY PARTY?
LET'S START THERE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE THING IS I HONESTLY THINK
ALL OF THIS OUTRAGE IS NOT
COMING FROM MIGRANTS AT ALL.
THEY WENT FROM VENEZUELA TO
AMERICA AND MARTHA'S VINEYARD,
NEW YORK CITY, IT'S ALL THE SAME
AND ARE NOT SAME ARE IGNORANT OF
GEOGRAPHY, IF YOU WANT TO COME
TO AMERICA YOU OFTEN CAN'T BE
PICKY OR CHOOSY.
>> Tyrus: IF YOU FOLLOWED THE
PROGRESSIVE'S ARGUMENT, THE ARE
ESCAPING.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD?
IT WAS OFF-SEASON, BUT STILL.
IT WASN'T THAT.
LABOR DA